the question is the final one you said I
was you know you know I was more you
know Trump camp and this this that I
realized I'm not a republican then
independent uh is anything with school
teachers today that you're still in
school are they have they influenced any
of your policies or your views while
you're going to school in a season like
this
okay we're doing school partially online
taking my
till longer than I should have
obviously doing work on the side that
would probably change my mind about
anything they would tell me but I've
seen I mean the things I've seen in
school I don't want to say anything as
I'm still in school right now but I mean
you can't it's very hard to escape
without being completely radicalized
like every class has some kind of
undertone of everything everything
yeah so so that's the part you know so
what are some examples of that like when
you say the undertone how much of it is
under the surface how much is this
full-on explicit what what have you
experienced I mean the p
the piece very explicit um before I went
to Penn I spoke to like an Alum because
I was very curious about like the
anti-israel sentiment on campus and I
mean she warranted me kind of what I was
kind of expecting but a little afraid of
um I think that's the worst part like
the anti-Semitism anti-israel bias that
part's really scary I think Colombia and
NYU are some of the worst in the country
which is crazy because New York is full
of Jews that's kind of all I knew I
didn't know how few Jews there were in
the country growing up in New York
because I thought everyone was Jewish so
that's pretty scary but I mean it's it's
hard it's every single class and it's
from current events to like you know Roe
versus Wade being overturned meaning
that we're mourning in class instead of
studying to literally literally to uh
that's what we don't know we were
mourning when Tupac died that was that
was yeah the teacher even was sitting
there so what a sad day I think my
friend at NYU said when Trump won and 16
they all were black to school for two
weeks because it was America's funeral
wasn't it yeah and they literally
started bringing in emotional support
like Ponies and like literally they
brought on the head like sessions where
people what did one of our girls here
said that she lost friends because she
didn't post uh
why don't you post this like what do you
mean why didn't I post it's almost like
the pressure to have to post it yeah you
know my kids right now are going through
the age where
uh there's bullying going on okay
and you know
Dylan doesn't get bullied you're not
going to use he's choked me out there
Dylan's the one that is the the kid
everybody wants to be friends with yeah
yeah because he's like if you're friends
with Dylan you're scored away he gets
the girls he gets all that stuff that's
Dylan he's got the energy Senna is the
center of all attention you know she's
like in the class she's a girlfriend
everybody wants to have so send us
friends are the pretty friends and all
this stuff Brooklyn is home kicking it
with Melbourne Papa she's chilling right
yeah but Tico is going through the phase
at 11 years old where things are
happening people are saying things
conversations are being had it's being
pushed he's coming home he's asking the
questions why do they say this why is
this happening and you have to know if a
person comes home today and they don't
have somebody to talk to to reason with
most of the time unless if this kid has
got a strong backbone character at that
age you're gonna cave because your
entire Mo in school when you're younger
is to what to conform and to be popular
you want to be cool you want people to
like you you want to be like man they
don't like me well she said I'm stupid
you know she said what a dumb thing and
then you're like oh my gosh she said
that and he said this so you're so much
trying to join the club and imagine like
even if when we went to school how much
do you remember when we went to school
how much do you remember politics being
involved zero I don't I didn't since and
because me and power both in the in the
in the military I didn't know what left
or right or anything was until I got out
and I moved to Los Angeles then I was
like holy like the Trump situation
made me go oh my God is it that is it
that bad that they don't want to lose
that that control in that power I did
you hear anything in school I don't
remember I mean listen it would happen
some things would happen and you know
people would make their comments but you
know to be everybody dresses black in
school because of what happened Trump
and Roe v Wade everybody's morning
instead of it is a it's got to be a
weird season today the one lady I'm
talking to uh who's uh one of the most
powerful Recruiters in the insurance
industry she's the executive she hires C
Suites for companies so she hires all
the c-suites for companies we're having
a conversation I said you know I have to
battle right now she's a little older
than me your kids are in their 20s I see
you know the the challenge with
parenting today is the goal is to make
sure you don't screw your kids up too
much okay because it's like you're
you're having to deal with how hard it
is to be a parent today but it's got to
be even much harder to be a kid today oh
my God from the angles you're being
targeted was it like that for you in
high school as well or not really
um I went to high school online because
I just wanted to tell you the Olympics
but in middle school I was bullied
really badly not over politics but I
mean I ate lunch in the bathroom for
months like I was really bullied so
thinking back now if that ended up being
political I don't know what I probably
would have done just to get to eat lunch
with my did that toughen you up a little
bit I think so so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]